he proposed and Rodrigo tourists yeah
man was so full chillin I was a show of
never sent Patrick's Day it was good dog
[ __ ] you know muhfuckas came out of
the pack it was uh was about almost 200
people don't so you free tonight
thursday night making me money hell yeah
it all me the money to feed everybody
got paid kept the show business 100 see
that I see that wasn't named showed up
by mr. green yeah for [ __ ] uh he's a
fan Don for the podcast all you showed
up but looks just like that full from an
IP board on a table he got mad faded
after two though how many foot with your
uncle shoulder right yeah like I haven't
seen imma be from Illya well uh he's
from Zacatecas originally came over here
when he was like 50 rabbit good time
yeah dude they had a good time I never
seen stand-up comedy live before how
about your brother went hell no [ __ ] him
I don't wanna do at home Haiti honey
foolish of a sad faces bro haha fool
chef mo showed up shut up shut up I
wouldn't put his ass up da computer shut
up just in a row to show to the right
gigs I that's what I'm saying folks I
was thinking about that for my teeth
this [ __ ] comes up a [ __ ]
throws a sub dog was PK initial yeah
[ __ ] PK came out with little suit and
[ __ ] we're story you know yeah I just
leave out to the shower bruh I gotta get
back to my lady yeah bro can't leave her
alone bro the dog tee ruk just can't
leave her alone bro hell yeah it was
cool about you doll house ybor city dog
oh the ybor city bro oh man I got you
some cigars oh hell yeah I left them in
the refrigerator yeah man I won't want
to his place color on mom you know it
with the people you got to cigars by
bunch of different place called la foto
una my fat I woman right Nate right next
to king corona right there where they
rolling up the [ __ ] cigar that there's
a gap in at the car he called him so
he'll chop o de Bourgh there was a lady
there who lose exactly like my sister
but it was curly hair and she took
photos I come she took selfies the arm
for my phone number I figured in the car
so I hear my phone number hope the most
tickets and they call yes I guy named
hair mine had mine out of my
he doin hooked it up because he works
there rolling up cigars hmm and it was a
tearful couple of shut up brought before
him to get these fools man make it
happen shout out to a mondo marine rider
a postal worker who listen to us and Joe
Diaz on his route shout out to j-roc
Castillo whose [ __ ] listening to our
podcast to catch up this food is busy
listening bro 93 episode that's over a
hunt over 200 hours yeah do you have
been seen as the side people need a life
alrighty and now Kevin Robinson who told
us how much he loved the pawn em sewed
last week therefore when I'm gonna go by
the book hell yeah David Gomez and
George Rae from San Fernando was so full
San Fernando thanks to all of you for
listening and talking about it on social
media also man it's been working man so
keep subscribing man and write a review
tell us how much you like where eagles
left in your ears and it helps man
because we will be made it to number 41
hell yeah no no me matter anytime we're
above [ __ ] wack ass Bob and Tom we're
happy bro well shall we beat them we're
successful bro that's what I'm saying
another to number 1 99 is she getting
beat by your comic with the swing vote
the swing vote but we got more
delegating [ __ ] south gate and they
do over there and and [ __ ] where they
front whenever they're from the Midwest
the Midwest bro holding in a lockdown
all right upcoming show New York City it
prefers for the hot 97 april fools
comedy jam at the theater at madison
square garden also initial Tracy Morgan
Rickey smiley DeRay Davis Dominique
Aries Spears Darnell Raleigh's oh yeah
and Felipe Esparza hell yeah doe Tempe
Arizona april seven through ten tempe
improv with Rogelio Torrez and Keith
manic give them to field get off the
field el paso texas April sixty one
night only at abril Chavez theater with
Rodrigo and Marcela I don't know about
Keith also Reno at Tahoe comedy club
inside a pioneer on the ground
Houston Texas April twenty-eighth remain
first what's up fool we want to just get
started man we have 0 a lot of things to
cover what you're gonna make [ __ ] up I'm
gonna give you the long intro the bill
for our next comedian Belliard I solid
food the first time I seen him was on TV
and I thought he was a radio star and
the second time I start with live fool
live where and I'm the bread improv you
wanna Jana brain problem fool that day
[ __ ] um I know he was opening and
Willie was picturing orbit reverse or
they were tag-teaming on feature an
opening for um dich nich Mulaney or
somebody or some other comic that was on
television I think it was the guy from
hang out some other show I don't know
but anyways do what happened to that
show was of course will you got loaded
right I need another beer bro Dave stole
somebody's jacket you gotta keep it hood
daubreuil always broke getting back to
this is funny man we have bomb and then
also when I was a haha cafe what time
you know so older comics or not they
don't have to be oh they could just be 9
20 years old but they've been doing
comedy with 16 which is no more mm-hmm
so their food giving advice to a bunch
of fools it with me I wasn't I was gonna
be made with my rounds with bands it
some other fools you know but I was like
I was like listening bro like trying to
get my ear and you know little fly on
the wall that advice that the
conversation wasn't for me but I'll
paying attention can remember so was a
comic said man what do you do ma'am when
the last kapiti just destroyed do it
dick and [ __ ] jokes it didn't like I
got close to because I know that [ __ ]
too cuz that's good killer I thought
that you know I gotta do dick jokes and
[ __ ] jokes to you know the same [ __ ]
right so my comedy was like trying to be
funny trying to be clean and trying to
be technical follow dick drilled hard
time so this food said that um put
yourself and not and the mindset of the
audience you know just to the last guy
did dick jokes you know they don't think
the others are they know that the whole
shows it'll be dick jokes and
now so you gotta just get the same
energy as the last guy did you know
whether you know you have to be a little
louder or or just do it over right so
man I try that shy the city of work walk
coyotes dogs the homeless animal
therefore if I'm stuttering to talking
hello is like studying a lot right there
are solid food american history x I'll
the most positive words to that movement
that boy was all [ __ ] up oh yeah the
jailed on he's the one that I'm he was
like therapy broke he was like a therapy
at that movie man is like after you
getting [ __ ] raped by nine Dick's got
it takes you back to reality the
soothing voice and then when I had an
interview on last comic standing there
they were asking me man who do you think
it would be the hardest do to beat
uh-huh and I said your guy torry and
Paula Bell is the next day the book the
ball got kicked off the show it was
fixed now it's surreal I say the
interviews guy torry Paula Bell the
Italian guy never heard of and all these
comics man but yeah the next day yes so
man with guy torry fool hell yeah dog
county right here now but all at me what
you think about the room up and you had
a room at commerce I've got when I
really a lot of fun yeah yeah yeah that
was from like the Rudy Moreno shows yeah
man Rena was consistently with paying
fifty dollars this up man so bad so yeah
it so you and you is that my old
stomping grounds we're not that old
stomping grounds but it at eboard just
started I mean I mean it will you
started earlier about ybor city and
tampa king corona that's why I go get my
cigars and right next door where I go
get a road too yeah I love I follow one
of the ladies she knows everybody yeah
yeah I kept I do my show and I go right
across the street I guess a guard I get
a drink and I sit back and just watch
the Freak Show on Friday saying I freak
so it's like Venice Beach it's like
village beiste meets Bourbon Street yes
yes are
first quarter yes if you are sure that
she is horrible maybe get it but it but
it's fun it's a pitiful on Kesha there's
a free show this to people who are just
dandy too yeah hell yeah yeah dress ya
ice yeah I you know it's like video
furniture benefit element yeah after
this freak show and total regardless
ladies in there with three titties there
is a pretty remember and temper your
fake titty ladies and I was supposed to
come to show the last time what the
cover shouldn't go I'll pull that way to
that for you but I titties fell asleep
yeah a good gum a lot of a man for said
three tiers one had an inverted nipples
that was that I'm happy what up man good
man man but i did that this is not
happen on Comedy Central already done a
show yeah Ari Shaffir your last night
last night bro and um el mágico I was on
right and your story he did not he said
memes bro he didn't hold back did hold
back some people just seem out this
comedian you know but I promise I'll bet
I said you know this time I Tatum this
is a show you know the Archimedean look
forward to man is Montreal and right you
get to go there and so I was there man
and you know keep in mind doing that
many Latinos their first of all other
brothers either go ahead camera in it
see we already that Donald Driver elbow
and yeah man I don't shop be running
Montreal common across many years never
tummy has us we're on an ethnic show ya
a dirty show yeah then we stopped doing
the as make sure they started putting
Italians and Greeks in it grow the laugh
at me as though they had it was all the
only ethnic person there was Bert
Kreischer no been to Russia and Eastern
you yeah it was Bert Kreischer mom it
was a Sebastian monocoque so hows about
yeah yeah Angeles to Salukis I am and
the only ethnic with Alonzo Bodden and
he was hosted damn well you know Alonso
we will oh yeah Cena that's why do we
all of we we we do below the black
community oh that's a representative
we're still waiting for other delegate
to come in yeah
ain't no cornel west yeah just a couple
of people that didn't get a chance to
hold okay yeah where Z that's my man of
course I love hahaha jalonzo man but
yeah he said he's in that Byron Allen up
Brian Gumbel was a lot funnier you know
not bigoted with my ass your suits so
positive positive you want a view
brothers would up with it with a season
kings hockey ticket oh yeah you got
season tickets in acidic to the Kings
why exactly do hockey we already skating
on thin ice you see you know I'm just
gonna cross over hey I gotta get that
this cross a long time ago man but yeah
he got his motorcycle he goes his Kings
games and clipper gain I think he's a
clipper season ticket holder too i think
i'm not sure but delivered the day you
know he does he's working he's good i'm
a man you know isn't that isn't that ben
Carson both are coming Alonso boarding
oh yeah the natural fudge cafe how long
ago was that man man with 94 95 96
really yeah i start i still i started
looking for i started 92 so one that one
that one that long before that you
started wearing new york or he's not
here la mamo to LA to get into the
finish my marketing degree to go to
school and I saw def Comedy Jam man it
was like whoa I'm funny to some of the
evenings so you know Omar walkins but
anyway oh no the bad dog dog you know
yeah I was like many he OTV let ain't
that ravenous you want to go man doodoo
brown doodoo this acting funny but you
know I saw you said you know do you see
like I can take him I know me I don't
see a do you sighs them up like you you
know if you can do could throw hands
like I said I was like I can take him I
could say and I was like Manny if he OTV
I know why someone said they saw Ernie
I can do that yeah bro Rose I mean
you've also made college does it look
like it's hard you know I'm saying it
look easy but when they started doing
this local at all damn it's it's as easy
as I thought but man I mean yeah some
cats you know that's what inspired me
def Comedy Jam is my key to starting my
engine well your brother were doing
comedy before he was I regional economy
are very successful is that he's already
on Def Jam like once or twice before I
had done stand-up well I always thought
you were coming in first no he he did
he's older he came in and he and I were
Yuri hosted my mama [ __ ] that be but
but he uh you know he's already when he
hosted FGM for the first time is when I
first a definite I had a chance to do
Jeff Jim the last season Martin hosted
but I wasn't ready I've been doing
comedy what a year maybe a little over a
year and then I wasn't ready I mean you
held yourself back I have well my
brothers like man you ain't ready I was
like yeah you're right but I didn't
doing it like after 20 little over two
years ago stand up i did in 1994 and the
def jam so things happen kind of like
really quick and i like got thrust into
like on tour like i went from doing just
clubs around la to like doing the def
jam tour so i went from really not
really learning how to work out I'm not
really have an act to actually being
thrust onto the big stage and then
thrust on this big tool we're doing
theaters and stuff so my [ __ ] happen
backwards I work myself I start the top
and work my way back down it's different
I we then started off in big ass
theaters yeah go to a small club and you
really will hear the energy are
different but you know don't you gotta
respect our mediums oh cuz I first of
all the bit that you know things like
wow you got to be bigger gotta be louder
cuz you got you know five thousand six
other people you know looking at you but
the thing about it is that you can't you
can't [ __ ] up they don't want to hear
beach they want to hit the top ten the
hits forget the Beast size in Toulouse
then pay thirty dollars for a damn
ticket or at least fifty dollars you got
to bring your damn a game what club at
least you have a little bit more leeway
you can you can you can [ __ ] around you
can play a little bit more it's more
intimate so you know I respect them all
then you move to freaking like you're
gonna redo the April Fool's one that's
probably a matter of square garden or
something
then you play those arenas it's like
whoa you got you got you got 14,000
people that's the difference so you
gotta respect each one and the timing is
different every one because we need a
smart club the laughs are immediate
banger then you want to think that you
got to wait a little bit you gotta wait
little because it laughs take a little
while to get to the stage and then you
do an arena your time has got to be even
slower because of our time you're moving
on to your next joke they're still
laughing at the joke you just told
you're just hearing laughter from the
next joke and you think you're not doing
well at first but it's like now you
killing it's just too laughs take awhile
to get there Rodrigo you're performing
arenas inside of clubs the lab I'll
story oh man yeah I'll magical
performance the oh man so I go to
Montreal man and I see another Latino
comedian and I seen this guy before man
and I look up to him and I say hey
Willie Barcena man how's it going man he
goes a bro talk to me when you say your
name writing oh [ __ ] really said that
yeah funny my man right there he's both
ways you know el mágico says el mágico
yeah I'm a gorilla ting is al Madrigal
bro there was some South Sider bro he
stood up said his name I don't write
that the times I my brain I was actually
opening I was actually featuring for
Willie yeah yeah Willie was headlining
that weekend yeah man so um so I'm how'd
you get in that movie mad Americans
reacts you know what man that movie man
you know it's all about you know do a
stand-up and being the right place the
right time in your material I actually
was doing fat tuesdays at night that I
create started right yeah sorry Fat
Tuesday I'm shooting a documentary on it
right now that's the night that really
started they're really the key to start
the engine was no white comet club doing
an urban night before 1995 bro Tuesday
none nowhere in the country so i started
Fat Tuesday the other room yeah and the
belly of exactly i started when i got
here 92 is after the riots the black
comedy clubs in south central comedy act
theaters it kind of died down and i was
out there doing stand-up and stuff but I
saw no industry down some lava is
showing by 95 @ agent and a manager
already and I said miss a lot a lot of
brothers and sisters getting looked oh
let me see if I know the comments don't
create my own night so so I can showcase
no other Camille I was still new myself
but i might bucket you know we do I said
enough money for all of us to eat hello
so I went the comic store that gave me
belly room and I packed that [ __ ] out
bro for like nine months straight like
turning people away and then I had to
move to the main room and then it became
you know it became like the night where
you know Nick Cannon was discovered and
Kevin Hart were coming through and
Richard Pryor would be the audience
Eddie Murphy and then sale and prints
and you name it so it became that night
with Hollywood kmec Black Talon and then
the improv saw much first of all improv
was mocking was mocking the comic store
for having [ __ ] night and then when
it's all said no real talkin stalking in
the documentary but then when they saw
much money the comedy show was making
they started their urban night of the
monday nights and then the Laugh Factory
starve the chocolate sundaes and an
improv started teasing it out across the
country there other improv around the
country so i'm glad they saw you know
the need for black comedians and and and
and just you know minority comedian
sound like using that word to have a
spot to go work out so big ups in your
improv I'm ready just trying to save my
dates on the roads like whoa BAM me and
that's a way for social media was it was
big bros packed everyone i wanna seize
every week now i was in there mom
Farrakhan son showed up i moost Lucifer
yeah yeah as my 30th birthday yeah
that's what stuff to freely for him to
back out of the that nice Shack was it
at night of bearish rock was it at night
Tommy Davidson car can I did the
clothing of car can I I mean everybody
was in as much Steve Harvey a Cedric
Bernie Mac they all came out for my it
was a surprise birthday party my sister
put it together and if I did all those
cast down and that's when I was out soon
the Kings economy to a definite I was
still young I was doing to economy seven
years at that point but man the fact
that they came out to see me was like
wow you [ __ ] kidding me these are
like guys who are like you know who am I
mentors and fartin came out that night
it was it was huge at night it was huge
bra i'm in relay him you remember that i
was outside of man i was outside by Tino
is chewy chewy was my domain I saw like
a motorcade darling what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is in there
president also bred Ferrari then a bunch
of um the fruit of Islam came out the
security guards uh-huh the color guard
yeah no they stopped traffic foo they
playing ain't playin dawg they stopped
traffic nobody get out to the Perkins
son left not like damn that's on the
best a big night I wasn't for them for
in fat tuesday i don't think they would
have been a Latino night I don't know
about that man i'ma let your girl I was
before Latino night right right right
right yeah I started 1995 so this but
not telling that story every night def
jam and all that [ __ ] I think that got
established first then let the I started
doing the def jam it was inspired me to
do anything that's that that don't Bob
something to put me on def jam with my
brother and and Martin those guys that's
what start the key to start the whole
engine for really for black stand up and
then you know I and the thing about I
was managed by russell simmons and
stanley who had done def Comedy Jam so I
wanted to do a night why can showcase
black comedians that was just a night
for me to work out and it worked out the
belly at the belly that's why I called
it fat tuesdays because I wanted to get
sponsorship from fat farm clothing line
hey got a fat tues that market eating
exactly 18 days back is a with my
manager something why not you know why
not do that and this did what it did it
did actually didn't actually Stan lasers
assistant and Russell's our sister
there's one who came in with the name
cuz I was trying to call her all type of
other [ __ ] funny farm I was trying to
get fat farm in there somewhere fat
Liddy fat jokes or something minutes 0
and this is why I say what night is she
said what night is and I said Tuesday
she said call her fat tuesdays like okay
all right you know it takes a woman
women are smarter than us any damn way
so took a woman to figure that [ __ ] out
the mid to give you all the door I got
the whole door but she got the better
dish you got the bar yeah you know
[ __ ] drink man was a tricky though
Trey I mean one time to pot cake and
it's funny because you've mentioned
chewy earlier two pockets just got out
of jail man and and chewy came to me and
was like yo guy pox down here with like
20 20 people alright and I'm like okay
let me ha dado you know and 2 i'd ever
seen you Chewie kind of like scared but
he had a little look on his face so park
was like yo man you know [ __ ] just
out you know I want to laugh and I was
like okay I got you in this big salad
bowl head dude and address them he said
when I say God I pay for everybody know
this your hustle and I appreciate that
because you know all those guys want to
get any free pack was like nah man and
i'll pay for this your hustle and then
he gave up there man he spent like I
don't know this is like 95 so he spent
like seven dollars on the bar like in 90
57 hours and drinking was a lot of damn
money and he speed buddy buddy chipped
away she's big he was it was just mad
cool man I was that was that fat
tuesdays was that spot it was that spot
to go to that's what Chris Tucker fifth
element they saw him in Friday at fat
tuesdays because there was too scared
the white cash and Asian was too scared
to go to the hood to see black comics
and they heard about fat tuesdays and
and and and they came to see Chris there
and he blew I remember that night he
blew that [ __ ] up that night blew it up
they gave him a thumbs up and he was
walking on stage damn yeah a lot a lot
of magic happen man uh and and Michael
Blackson man you know I was gonna shoot
a documentary I never thought it was
just a comedy night but then Michael
Blackson was on the plane one time he
was like man people don't know because I
stopped at a 22 in twenty ten and twenty
ten and uh no and o 5 i'm sorry no.5 and
he goes he goes yo man people don't
understand what what fat tuesdays meant
to black comics man that somebody need
to tell that story i was like huh I
never thought about it like that and I
was like okay what I mean it's because
he that's how he got he got saw Michael
got put on what the next Friday
franchise he was there one night Ice
Cube song it was in the audience it was
like y'all I want him in the movie so
that's what that's what fat tuesdays
well that's what some comic level should
be that's why when you go on stage you
should always at least give in at least
eighty percent of your best cuz you
never know expressly in Hollywood you
never know who's in the damn audience
verragio sort of your setlist and say
them in American she wrecks they
actually came down and see this whole
thing about my future ex I was at the
calm me ask the Aspen Comedy Festival
and had a manager at the time it was
smart who said man you gonna be so hard
up at the Comedy Festival for every
industry person that don't go they're
gonna see you at fat tuesdays he said
god I need about 250 seats just to
invite 250 industry people down he's
coming used Tommy Davidson is to draw
and have you open for Tommy Davidson to
a special fat too
don't host go to do a set and there's
you and Tommy Davis well my boy at the
time we was hanging tight with Dan and
green was comedian yeah and I was trying
to you know I was like a man's coming a
lot of eyes in there man you know I'm
have you go up I'm convinced my manager
to have you do like seven minutes man go
up there and blaze that [ __ ] so so they
can see you so you can sneak you in that
said I can't go up cold I got my boy
warm up so they let him warm up and then
I went on and then uh Tommy Davidson
went on and they actually came down to
see Tommy Davidson for american history
x damn that was they came to see him and
then I ended up um I ended up just doing
a set about stupid racism is no matter
what your ethnicity and I thought my
material was better for the role plus
I'm sure I was cheaper than Tommy Davis
is that kid be 100 at the same time but
but but that road that row was was was
pivotal man ed Weinberg was in at night
the creative taxing Mary Tyler Moore
cosby show the whole nah he just created
show called sparks sparks in sparks with
Terrence Howard Kym Whitley arif Kenshin
Miguel Nunez and James Avery from The
Fresh Prince so then when um when he saw
me at fat tuesdays man he had another
sitcom called good news he had created
like you know like the Amen but a
younger version amen and he end up right
in a row for me and that aneta and that
sitcom for me so it's been you know when
your stage man is always as always so I
was good to blaze that [ __ ] we didn't
get [ __ ] I've let you donate not a dad
down scout you got pulled over let you
know now we go [ __ ] whack a promoter the
fluid us to fluids out to Tucson for a
hundred fifty dollars one of those days
Bugsy's that's funny [ __ ] whistle over
celebrity we have one lo peor Rivera you
shut up on a red hummer nobody knew who
the [ __ ] he was only me Bob Mexican do
with Jordans look at you down
[ __ ] that was funny man early apology
who is short one time man hell yeah nice
to run out to him with his drink Cuddy
and coffee cookie and coffee cuz I knew
I get free drink ticket so I didn't
drink so I'll see Paul [ __ ] show up so
I just waiting for him then I just um I
give the Filipino get my drink ticket
and it goes Paul what do you want man
whatever he wants yeah what oh where
George Lopez Oh what's up fool so
somebody's in a bowl something lazy was
so cool hello hello from the other side
hello right Oh Joel opposed protocol in
promoting show with him in Morales oh
man oh man Jose Lopez man hates recourse
etrade whatever name is George or Geneva
opening for George George Lopez in
Sacramento man and liked it the mid-90s
man and when I say he was like a
technician like I learned so much from
that weekend man he was he had every
joke written down had notes by it had I
mean and I never read and that's why i
started nice to write just scribble
notes down but when i saw george lopez
do that man i was like wow that's
Candace I like to me and I said it
didn't he's like you know to me was like
the Latino Richard Pryor I mean he was
just like I learned so much from his cat
man and and and and he was nice but he
was like he was blazing the stage every
show every weekend it was just like as
hard as it's like the laughter that was
coming I know lap climbing clubs could
get that loud and you're up with such
laughter when I when I was opening for
George Lopez I mean he was he was
blazing this [ __ ] you know he was [ __ ]
that when you when you're young you
think you'll set is dope and then you
got somebody going behind you like Manny
little punk-ass Joe get home you got
your set like yeah I'm gonna rip this
[ __ ] up tonight and you know you do well
you get a nice artice respond but there
you go see somebody take it to the whole
nother level like me you're gonna jokes
like you little punk ahead get the [ __ ]
out of here
[ __ ] hands jokes well George Lopez
before he had his sitcom yeah up to
Latino night under the only time I ever
seen him a Latino night and I'm you
Sandra Bullock was there a lot of people
he's a 45 man is broke kill ya of [ __ ] I
never heard yeah yeah I heard a later
but never heard before I killed bro hit
that drove a ball Tom about Hillary
wanna go to Dodger Stadium and his mom
brought bologna sandwich Dodger Stadium
yeah and now he has his mom how come we
don't have hot dogs because you're not
[ __ ] Steve Garvey that that's even
down to games all the time to climb a
cardinal fan so he judge go there two
men oh yeah that's right baby stl 315
st. louis MO that's where you're from
st. Louis yes sir Rams are back baby
this was on your alley round fan yeah
Simon st. Louis Rams fan so I mean
people say Lewis don't like me because
I'm rude I was rooting for them to come
back here but I'll live here I want to
go to eight home games a year without
Arizona try to see Adam fly to Sakura
Seattle I mean a San Francisco for Game
I walked down I live downtown LA first
three years they played at the Coliseum
walk down in stumble the hell back to
back and watch her go to an alley Rams
Oakland Raider game oh man your vests I
have drama where my life saw a black
vest right again I have a ram game all
day long all day strong yes sir I user
hell yeah dog no Last Comic Standing
thing man was like what was that like
for you man it was what happened that
night man you know me my whole thing was
it was a big lie I felt like when they
they they call me five or six time to do
that damn show a nice kept saying no
first of all they called me to host the
show like they said Oh Last Comic
Standing is interested in you hosting
the show so what happen to build bellary
so they're going to different directions
I said okay cool then I hear it I his
[ __ ] for like six months then I heard
like Oh last comic standing collar in
which I said hostess ain't no I'm said
I'm doing that doing that show and then
they kept calling me kept calling my
agent and was like oh you have a good
chance of winning the show and none of
this and I was like nah
you know I'm good and then I asked some
friends of mine who done the show Rob
Harris and you know Steve Wilson I was
like okay lavell Crawford they did the
show they were already there been in the
game long before me I said well is like
man opening up to a whole new audience
man you can work clean and I said okay
well I like challenges I'll try to do it
and then it just it's just downhill from
the from the audition man and and they
they were they were I got a Carmen at
night I I made it past I got a call from
Dante know who did it the first time is
dr. yeah danke meeting Dante I don't
know how he found out you got her I
don't know how you got my number he's a
guy heard you went on you made it to let
the next round I said yeah you know he
said bro i'ma tell you right now have
any nude pictures out there any any
lawsuits anything get rid of that stuff
I'm like what say man I'm just telling
man NBC is gonna be in your ass I just I
just blew it off so then so then when I
start doing when I did the show you know
I like two weeks before i'm getting
ready to UM to do the you know that i
got a call from NBC legal hey this is
Roger so and so and uh oh yeah so uh you
got a DUI in 07 I said no it was wit
rims a wet reckless Evan okay well how
many drinks are you drink said I'm a
comic we drink for free well I mean
drinks in the week how many pics of the
day they do drug you smoke crack I'm an
out what the [ __ ] is this did he say
well you have any new photos out there
anything like that knows are you married
and I'm said I'm divorced oh do you beat
your wife why are you divorced I'm here
and I was playing pechanga at the time
right so I'm like at the outlet on the
phone with this NBC legal guy like the
girl is just as he grilled me about this
[ __ ] for laughter that I just like man I
told Barry cats know whose management as
I said man I gotta get off this show I
said I'm not feeling it so that guy just
go on and I said alright well we'll see
what happens so then you know how they
had you type your set out words that
word the FG type you set out
word-for-word word-for-word lawyer like
two or three weeks before the set so I'm
gonna roll right through Road dates so I
ok imma tighten my setup I'm a trim the
fat so about four days before we grated
film I send them an email saying hey I'm
doing the exact same set I just changed
a couple of things here it is and I said
my email back saying I'll stick to what
we stick to what you sent us I said but
I made it funnier I tighten it up this
is stick to what you sent us or you
won't air so I send them back I
guess I won't air sinned and I and I and
I did the set that I changed and when
you look at this he was added my boys 05
was there truth in a top that set up
somebody to begin sue that set the [ __ ]
that I could add if they did not bucket
I mean it was a crazy experience man
because it was it was I'm Greg on stage
in the stage manager right before I'm
going on stage is talking to me man I
loved in American she reacts I'm like
[ __ ] mother go home stays on TV and
[ __ ] perform in the content and
you're talking about some old airs movie
idea anyone like a youngster like
assistant dude stays erect he was like
an older guy like you should know better
good good it was it was just weird and
then when I when I you know it's funny
because i knew i was gonna make it to
the next round so I came back on stage
with my garment bag oh my god you get
that oh darling there picking a cob be
ready Oh watching a ship today the for
the suitcase as i know i'm going home so
why does the future so the producers was
like but deuces are like our guy torry
has his garment bag he's like yeah you
can't bring those i'd say why can't he
can't bring it they talk to the truck
gacho has a garment bag on stage he
won't he will he walk he won't leave it
and this it all forget it let him go i
mean i'm like hey what's right now i'm
going on why the [ __ ] out play the game
bucktown ass that was funny halves of
the bag yeah man i was like going for
broke cuz I'm like I'm like if I problem
mama makes him no other one makes him
know what did you say you turn about you
did a bitter but you went to a black
clan rally right yeah this is a thing
and it's that criticism with what killed
me because um I said I said oh I said
bush was so bad that the clan started
voting for barack obama i said i was
going i said did this show in Kentucky
somewhere I'm going through the limo
drivers take me to my hotel I saw if
you're going through the trees I saw a
burning cross like wow that's a goddamn
Clara Valley I said I said Palolo I
never been to a Klan rally so then as i
thought it i said so i said i got then
the grand was like here here here we
going we gonna we gonna we gonna vote
for the [ __ ] some [ __ ] like that but
anyway but the criticism was but God
that didn't really happened
but are you kidding me no Natasha yeah
it was a touchstone or arado Gerardo and
I'm like are you kidding me I mean of
course it didn't really happen we in
battles were coming okie think a monkey
suck his dick Andrew surprise ever real
I mean is this your criticism nothing
neither why are you my [ __ ] follow me
on stage so you know but what did you
say was real and I know I know I heard
Natasha fatale brokers you know coming
to comic hell yeah he said lady you're
here play the rooms I play yeah it's
like when I'm is live with my wife it's
like when Patrice O'Neal told uh what's
his name wrong like in the comedy Rose
what's the name oh uh um would you look
like a Jew Sonic well at you doesn't it
today said in my world you're an open
mic yeah and to know people in it laughs
but if you're a comic yeah hurts bro oh
you know what that I know who you are
you could be then cook or whoever but
see there's certain worlds you're afraid
of walk into yeah not like Mexican and
black me they walk it everywhere because
we want to work everywhere letting us
but you know what we know we are so our
comedy is so real because we know the
[ __ ] we have to deal with you know in
this country I mean comedy is truth in
pain and and and and we do comedy
because we have dark places on the
inside of us and that comedy brings
light to those dark places so when we
bring that at drama net pain to the
stage after the real [ __ ] comes up we're
not [ __ ] privilege to or have a sense
of entitlement we [ __ ] bring our
comedy from the struggle that we gotta
come through from our neighborhoods from
from being in this Donald Trump ass
[ __ ] country hell yeah and that's
what it is so Donald Trump [ __ ] man is
because you know they hate Barack is
he's black and he and he's the leader of
this country and its own as white men
you know I see the look how they look at
me when I'm in sitting in first class
they going back to coach I said look at
me like what the [ __ ] are you doing here
a free [ __ ] what's not huh but funny
like and I like the people who are
following Trump and let how do we get
this other copies man those are not
[ __ ] supporters
other groupies huh it's like black
people with Michael Jackson we we know
michael prior [ __ ] boy but I did
Edison Jackson fail we do here i reduce
the Rogues oj we know Jay disenroll [ __ ]
but you know what we love them as a we
go support a week Trump supporters say
no Trump a kiss check it will be a
terrible president and the shitty saying
is wet but you know what they sticking
by they got it sticking by their guy so
you know I'm a dad on me I'm never
[ __ ] with miska we don't stay bari
guy hell no no Richard Ramirez we beat
his ass Halloween csj we still he
mexican if you're amazing you [ __ ] up
you're on your own bro she advise
bringing shame to our family I won't see
like what police brutality's police
potential Mexican well you know what man
I obey the rules bro I break long time
yeah people tell me to sit out I sit
down cross leg drop oh baby i'm very
obedient I've been hit before by my
parents hard-hit I've been beat we got
we got women's with shovels my dad was
military so he they said was little you
know it'll issue military shower with
her let us hit a pickle one without
those matt attack yeah my dad whip ups
with that man deign to bend over like we
were getting initiated to a fraternity
or some [ __ ] man and he may got wet i
make us sweat our drawers first like you
go wet the drawers let's roll back over
and then and then whimpers [ __ ]
hazaea acts absolutely that's my walk
with a limp now got them my friend would
always say she let that what happened
from it they got whipped the moment
beneful we talk bragging about not
eating it really whipped that what about
we weren't short yeah yeah what the belt
is rough hostile [ __ ] man went to Bel
Air wet shorts man and ice got the worst
I should wet the best I was 13 so I got
my god I got hippie boy yeah i was
already wet slip and slide ass but we
didn't why do kids with the bed broke my
little brothers to with the middle of
time and then my mom should figure if I
get hit him more
but you never stop I saw some sensor you
have no idea what it is that is that I
stopped wetting a baby when I started
jacking off girl time and it's funny
because I discovered in town she knows
one day I used to do a joke about
wetting the bed and you should joke
about the first time I ever jacked off
but I was on stage where they had the
Epiphany and I was doing I never did the
jokes in the same set before and this
particular night I end up doing the
jokes in the same set and I was like
wait a minute as the core legs I stopped
wetting the bed and 13 start jacking off
at 13 I was like why I guess I found a
better use for my dick I never go to bed
I never with the baby I knew I thought
you started drinking doing drugs I still
wit the bed hey don't ya all the faculty
just go probably some little switch
however just peeing on myself and waking
up and they're pretending like I didn't
pee on myself at your tuna party [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it cuz you when you let that [ __ ] w
likes wallet didn't shoot him myself
that before there I said it myself
before twice goes man as an adult I was
too huh what did I was this I was I was
doing a movie Pearl Harbor right so we
in Pearl Harbor yeah you're in a cannon
huh yeah I was a little black ball in
the care I was the [ __ ] suit thank
you a good was only brothers really in
that mama well count Cuban I'm not white
I'm not black i'm oj the people versus
keep ma hey that's the guy yes that's a
good series but watching that [ __ ] yeah
hell yeah what do biog now hey man OJ's
innocence Rosie but here I was doing I
was doing Pearl Harbor man and there's a
scene in Pearl Harbor where the bomb
hits the boat in and you see the player
they see the sailors underwater swimming
with an American flag and all that [ __ ]
right so they gave a scooter because
scuba training so I had to go do scuba
gear I all have session to go do our own
private scuba training to swim
underwater like that well I drank the
night before a lot in the next morning
you know just was a swimming on empty
stomach so I ate some I was running late
and it was on the Warner Brothers lot on
in the valley and had a swimming pool
out there
this guy was come by selling muffins on
the [ __ ] lot I hired a bran muffin
hey I ate a bran muffin and had the
scuba gear but on a scuba suit it zips
up in the back right so I just I i was
jobless drinks like a hangover hangover
[ __ ] trying to come out I had eight in
the bran muffin and I'm in the pool when
I'm in the scuba suit and I and I had to
go i hope felt my stomach boom boom boom
and I said dude just instructor said
where's the bathroom the bathroom was I
had to get my car and drive to the
bathroom in a wet suit in a wet suit so
I got my truck I'm driving to the back
I'm driving to the bathroom I haven't I
didn't take the keys out of my ignition
or close the door I was running trying
to zip it down at the st. that the the
scuba suit down at the same time and I
didn't make it man party just just just
a mudslide all down my leg all in super
sooo much and I went got back in the
pool yeah did you get a new body suit
same one hey man I didn't tell dude what
happened I just and I had someone gonna
say [ __ ] literally danske have fish food
on him feces you see a man I had a lot
of moments like that man is I'm not
proud of but you know do the movie car
don't set we're going to the word he
murphy and michael douglas i played this
killer and father Jensen a very
beautiful pharmacol Jensen played
Michael Douglas's wife we kidnapped a
little girl and [ __ ] like that but
there's a scene where I I'm choking her
I'm a topper from choking her writing
the cameras like in my face and I gotta
make it real I gotta sell them chuckling
hell out this [ __ ] right so I'm holding
my breath so veins could pop in my full
hair so I'm real like I'm choking too
hard but I eaten a banana and drink some
coffee before so uh what that up so
Coffee bananas and that should go though
so I'm choking her but I'm holding my
breath of the vein so that air had to
get out somewhere and every tank I'm
sitting on her chest and just blown HS
upon her face was real because she was
smelling my ass and then looking back
it's the site and
beautiful woman I want to / / / / every
take forever and she never spoke to me
again I saw Runyon Canyon with that and
she just would've brought it over though
as i hain't far because she just looked
at me and just kept her breath and this
is like years later haha mudslide number
two hello everywhere we shall like such
juvenal comment about [ __ ] jokes and
fart jokes but they never you know they
never you know he'll know what are the
moves you been on man ah that's true
that american history x those guys used
to go through those they have real class
members every skin is get heads when
director who one who was he and he was
jewish and from australia so he had just
as much to fear too so we he wanted to
he wanted he wanted it really was i
guess it was the orange county and was
right there was a course got your corn
concert and i think they busted like 30
days yeah and and and they busted like
the route of skin is cuz they won he
want the real look man and i'm telling
they couldn't wait to say [ __ ] day was
that was the only line it was one would
up [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
they couldn't wait to say they want the
rehearse I'm like are you buggin ya
water good good good good good good good
good good guy was here right look then
she gotta get that chin then overdose
overdose but yeah man we had a set full
of nothing but skin has a lot of days
man and of course you have to eat you
eat by yourself see so they could be in
character and may head Norton was in
character the whole time and phenomenal
actor man but he was I was trying to
really figure out using characters not
seem as you know we didn't really [ __ ]
around each other doing the whole shoe
so therefore sterling character the
whole time to the whole set pretty much
man sonic annoying [ __ ] haha
acted I give a man you free welcome to
him man he goes man you know where the
bathroom is guess over there
[ __ ] no yeah right with it what
do the hit little boy with a hitter side
man with others over there man who did
that on Trump's I'd be nice pastor
Donald Trump sign now got people Bobby
Myers yeah he'll help i'm sorry american
history x ya seen entertainment when you
start watching it man i guess they made
it the
we looked like he's making sense in a
way huh without his racist of you saying
cuz there's couple of scene when you
want to agree with him but the 99 nice
racist well when it starts off with the
whole thing about the riots right his
dad was a fireman [ __ ] and I killed him
or some [ __ ] and that's what we're
talking about those Mexicans too oh yeah
some of the thought he was a man like my
dad say the same things about
salvadorian people though you notice he
races or the class today they let me add
live a lot in that movie man and there
the director let me ad lib allotment we
go over for the laundry room well yeah
we will go over we go over his house and
uh and and right scenes like we like
somehow we got on the word [ __ ] I don't
know how we got on the word [ __ ] and I
said you know what I'm not supposed I
said I'm supposed to be one and don't
know what the definition of one is so he
said guy we have some consultants in
Orange County from South Africa know
some skinny as consultants so he got on
one phone I got another phone they
didn't I was on the phone he said hey
this is tony kaye from the movie two
brothers called two brothers in first or
what Americans read today uh what's the
definition of deafness of a [ __ ] he
adept at Australian accent what's your
definition of a [ __ ] and the guy goes
uh hold on a minute and he goes any girl
ass alright knows like gonna go get one
here's a look a bit of skinhead
dictionary so he comes back and like
well someone who lazy worthless and
should go back where they belong I'm
like what they what Simone iggins United
States and I thought a lot of us ain't
from here in the first damn place so
then he goes what do you hate think all
black people [ __ ] said no only some of
them I'm like wait the only hate [ __ ]
on the weekend so I came up with this
thing if you if anybody seen the move is
a scene where we're folding sheets and I
make that I make the take the sheet and
make a clan hood out of it that scene
was totally like aunt lived in written
not even really in the script they make
up sex scene all that stuff they let me
they let me just ad-libbed and the whole
laker the whole legacy and I'm a big I'm
a big-time Laker fan my whole life since
I moved before I moved to LA and and
they're known as a Boston Celtic fan so
we were just braces like look turn the
camera on let's just go let's just peek
from the bucket and heart and that's the
NASA [ __ ] that made the movie cool
oh yeah that's badass that's that's
great filmmaking like that you know when
you get a director who trusts you and
they let you go same thing with the
movie life first day on the set Eddie
Murphy told the director you know it's
pretty Mac and Miguel Nunez you had
Martin Lawrence you had myself yet you
had Anthony Anderson and he told the
director first day let them go let them
I trusted not the man live and much as
they want to and usually get you get you
get an actor who who is who is kind of
like insecure they want to hold you back
Rob Schneider but anyway oh god you guys
and not let and not let you shine like
Eddie Murphy day one was like man yo
let's have fun you can't do it bro you
can't do it bro no he's as it is what it
is man you know I have no filter magnum
[ __ ] I've dropped name that's what so
once when I was with cat will embrace
all right man you know what man I I've
been that [ __ ] up dude what's on some
furrows man when you're on coke when you
party hard you do get to that level
where you're in the hood of a sudden and
but now there's cameras connect an image
manal at a time when I will go from a
comedy show hanging out at the after
party with these [ __ ] and then
some of the [ __ ] leave so I'm
hanging out with a new mother [ __ ] who
wasn't even at the [ __ ] show and now
we're in a [ __ ] hood dog right and
I'm like daytime and then like and then
I'm talking I'm talking and then there's
some fools laughing over here but you
already all [ __ ] up right so you gonna
collect is no what the [ __ ] you guys
laughing at and I how the fight started
see what cat man where people don't know
is Casa genius like let's do you put him
on your show I see Lori on your show we
started he was coming up to that show I
mean he was already making a name for
itself but cat IQ is 162 net Mincy level
like the Howard Howard Hughes he's that
type of genius I'm not just saying it
cuz he's just he's literally a genius
but when you're that intelligent and you
smoke the wacky tabacky that who we you
you can't you they don't mix well so you
do crazy [ __ ] so like like like like
like when you got intelligent you smoke
weed you get dumber Oh may I smoke weed
I guess
order I was at it works the opposite and
cat if you go get it literally a genius
and like when you smoke like that you
can't you can't be that intelligence so
like he's getting and I'm sorry I'm
defending him because that's my dude
right but I'm like a trump supporter
that's getting harder and harder to
defend but boy I don't think he's on
weed though I don't think that's just
weed as we mask must know anything who
hate the weed face I'm deep in a tux
blue red we had it links to we'd
probably little bitter like I know it's
wacky tabacky yeah well assemble some
special sauce but he's a genius man I
mean I goal I know but you know come on
cat that's my do but it was gonna be
hard to defend you in a minute who knows
40-man like it we thought that he will
sit here I got back he was shaved down
cat got some hands man but he was
sitting down you know after they broke
up the fight they were say man we're the
same side man he was he might be but we
the same size you see how dorky was hey
what about that everybody was look he
was hanging out with a screener cookies
Shepherd oh you when you beat up the
chaperone hallo alle and lightly Lonny
Breaux and Rishon believe what they cat
cats always been centric like that
though I remember before he got put on
put on man Cat Cat would had a he always
had that pimp persona but he had a
stretch he had a stretch escalade
explore with coach likes like before he
was like he can he'll still fabulous he
was still got that back then with the
train he brought up people have the fat
tuesdays and he had a stretch explore I
know they stress explorers haha better
stressed explore with coach lights a
bunch of women with him and he always
had that you know that Bernie always had
that look so it's not like oh he you
know he started making interchange can
say same person same dude huh yeah I'm a
heaping let me but he always had a brush
why we scatter yep kept a hat on cuz
you know yeah bad hair day someday that
will say I've been arrested 38 times
never been a gel 10 months you ever been
to a court course what he knows what
he's doing man you know I'm like you
know it's a good way to promoted the
tour that's lame think Donald Trump does
he just puts it out there you know in it
no one gets then he knows you to get our
million dollars worth of free press he's
feeding people yeah yeah he's a number
one topic it was a number one theme
trending last night and there was a
[ __ ] debate last night oh yeah that's
Jeannie has debate and Brussels
impressive can fire far ahead Brussels
and EP he ain't mad it was more out of
tarrant and not worn away for cats ya
know I had a cup of prey for cash oh
yeah it was a cup of break but gas man
the best whatever red was you know those
army was a brother in the hood you know
it was a black light matter he was still
waiting on Paris to pray for pray pray
for Chicago this is still waiting I'm
pret à Paris to Chicago Iraq so what
deal about this whole thing a man about
that the whole thing is going on with
debate right now between Donald Trump
and Hillary and the stuff they saying
and the people that are following him
between these people that were following
him had always been around but now
they're coming out of the bed around
yeah yeah I been a bit look I always say
this man it's like did you see that on
the road or you just feel because man so
I saw always there I saw it when I had a
lady for water my face in Toledo Ohio
cuz i was doing some romney jokes rather
romney lost shut up the penguin seats
yeah she was she was pissed man is a lot
of there's a lot of you know pissed off
people get that you know we got a black
president and they want to say that he
ain't did anything whatever you may need
to do anything unemployment is down it
is four point nine percent what do you
mean on economy's bad I nine years ago I
should go film is you via cost me 150
bucks last week 55 damn dollar fifty
five we're gonna tell me that we ain't
we better off right now I said nine
years ago
gonna have to go window shop at Whole
Foods I can [ __ ] it actually buy some
hopeful and take your [ __ ] on the same
day I'll have to put on gross don't lay
away any damn oh me too but no more
samples for me yeah I'm buying the whole
economy I mean the whole this whole
thing is just you know it's just it's
just you know mad as all white men their
own and mad huh yeah that's gotta tell
into those old [ __ ] is still
alive but here's the thing though the
mad because they said there's no jobs
their jobs it's just what companies have
done that starting high women that women
in those jobs so they got smart and I'm
women in those positions but the [ __ ]
up thing is is that they're hiring women
and putting women in those positions but
they're saving money because
unfortunately not paying and women the
same as the males in that same position
so that they're doing that doing a
service and a disservice to say you take
that one yeah so in me then I tell you
that side always hard more women yeah
but but but look at what you're paying
the women and paying the men for the
same for the same position so it's you
know it's it's this corporate America i
I can't agree with getting corporate
America out of politics I think that is
part of the problem because I want a
reason why a lot of our foods are [ __ ]
up because the politicians are passing
in some of these laws and these food
corporations are putting this bad [ __ ]
in food but because their lobbyists and
they and they pay these politicians
they're like overlook some of the bad
[ __ ] that we have in our foods so I'm
all for getting corporations out of
politics I'm awful at how they're gonna
run at the money gonna give no money
though I know well you did you yeah you
got you Kasich has got it is fun fun his
own campaign Trump it's fun in his own
campaign so they say so I mean and
Bernie Sanders yeah Bernie Sanders
probably the one that's doing it like
all by himself grasp what's Trump Trump
tea with you to realize there's Trump
Justin nomination he gets that money
back the money he's spending any telling
that pot he gets that money back now
Bernie's and [ __ ] out of luck unless and
that's hopefully Hillary makes him as a
vice I like to see Bernie old ass his
advice hey somebody got the young vote
cuz he look like a [ __ ] Muppet like
100 Muppets that's why you got a [ __ ]
boat I also see Bernie sat in the new
Back to the Future movie he looks like
that guy doesn't like I get it crystal
here's of Aloha yeah brisa don't look at
that gate every move is about to see the
world they only listen the only listen a
step oh [ __ ] my papers fell lot of order
let the guy man the coming to the
world's gonna head man just believe me
bro yeah hey don't have the face that
you gonna believe him I know that and
then inkay oh and cruise I don't trust
this much my fast oh [ __ ] you can you
get no come on and here's a faith hill
Ted Cruz a face like he just did a bad
job but nobody laughs yeah exactly like
me Oh laughs Tommy's dead that face for
Marco Rubio's I said Omar oh right now
the other politics he's like I'm done he
goes back to the private sector day how
we know more after last comic get me
whatever will gots it the hell home
harden abhi tuk that food down did they
cut the money off yeah little Rubio look
that yeah truck killed a man Trump did
Trump did Rubio like if you have you
seen the shack rose that I'm own but
it's jamie foxx oh my god how was that
live oh my god he'll do here we back
flips bro delivery they said well how
was that I [ __ ] planned know when we got
here with what we got that you never
liked that guy know what nano system
they told us they all gave us microphone
said look we're gonna Mike you
individually because you can heckle
anybody want to do in the whole row oh
my god that we saw Doug Williams and we
was like oh dog you know dog is funny
but like how the hell he get on it on a
dais and then an ends out so early
cheatham
haha i read and and I mean I've seen
that damn clip a thousand times man and
I laugh every thousand times G I me a
conscious I mean we would die a
conscious and it may Jamie got a lot of
people that night moose Johnson used to
play for the UH dallas cowboys they
didn't air that part but he was ready to
fight you worried what Jamie yes shut up
he's lying Jamie winning him so bad he's
but he was winners find this clear his
wife came his wife came to a Shack like
Shaq you can air this he's a broadcaster
in the ruin his career and chakra a man
inside the country yo yeah that was that
that was still the funniest thing I
think I've ever seen on a roast it is
I'm your conscious much I'm not Jamie
I'm your conscious oh my god Doug
willing went down here when he said to
Jennifer you know your first couple of
more didn't do so well right yeah have
you ever been in a movie and a cosigner
one on a cosine anyone I just did
another job that did were over but
that's what that's what Trump did to
Rubio man he shut him down doing and he
couldn't come back after that man exited
start out with dice tu conciencia didn't
start out with a regular political
discourse she's just not man's ass hey
you know I gani I think you whip [ __ ]
Jeb Bush more all right I when I think
he could I think he [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
up Jeb Bush Martin Mario beat Jeb Bush
more bro he was handing out those
insults like a boss for like [ __ ]
like on that show dog until the muscle
is how he felt I love that rushed it was
like a dude that's been watching fools
get roasted all his life he's been
writing down good jokes I'm gonna say
this for your mother [ __ ] we ever see
take booze again if I ever see Jeb Bush
I got something for this [ __ ] ok
mama just hold on to that one then he
was waited and waited and waited but the
best one was when he was saying all hit
all of his money was trying to back up
his mother's integrity by barbara bush
and then Donald showing looked over his
they were maybe your mom should run
that's fighting were all just been quite
late like [ __ ] Hank Hill her it's cuz
that fool it comes with is a different
animal dog he has his own money and
those fools come from [ __ ] people to
put money in a mirando it's like having
a big dog Ronnie huh if he had [ __ ]
Donald Trump money forget about it dog
forget it by the broad tell them how to
read dog imagine if [ __ ] big dog at
george lopez money dog and I'm saying
come on fool everybody watch the lopez
show on TV land mar 30 my stories always
i start on the internet uh the the whole
episode yeah the first part of the
highlights I talking a grosser than a
bro oh hell yeah it was funny scene
because I'm Terry Gross is just standing
right there and I'm our jalapa shows up
and then he just sees a motion named
Tony Burgos just I didn't know the black
suit red tie and he has over the keys
like he puts a bat in his car and then
i'm tony was Charlie he's good at
o'neill's good actor boy yes Syrian
rebel look at cars on [ __ ] more also
bans is in the show and that other big
fool tuna see trick see sink riata
whatever he is or back people our first
bathroom break cat ever hunt till I
drink a gallon of water a day man i'm
running like man and zip that bad how do
you stay so young man he looked the same
a man it's called a nipple juice so we
had to scrunch over here last week
that's a smooth version of scrunch oh
yeah was he got did he tear anything up
nah man nah it's cool he dropped a lot
of money though scotch oh man i remember
he first started man scratch Ojeda he's
head shot was here with no shirt or like
a black chip and dale like the chitlin
that's right that's right there so him
yeah and I was like dog if you really
want across here yeah as if you wanna be
taken serious man you gotta you gotta
losers what an answer for real man
really I remember this karmic he came
out to me around me and Gabriel Gless
illegal it gave her man I got it Mike I
made up a little real you didn't go show
it to Nickelodeon that's right forget
rules and all that in the junket right
and he was a couple of things dog and
man it was like it was a good real for
acting like the rivers there were there
Casting Sons of Anarchy or hey or on the
wire or something cousin he shot or is
shooting someone in every scene and one
scene he's a bunch of you took his shirt
off but to get up with a white chick
about raper and then another scene he
was that he leaves well no some other
brother oh and that was actually all
surveillance footage yeah goes all black
and white that was that with a little
time code at the bar and this is darius
well he got it act on using that no [ __ ]
you got dates coming up that days i'm in
denver this weekend man different improv
man uh come what city Denver Colorado
man yes we've done their improv whenever
they were the same it to a play with and
say yeah you're here at the Chicago
improv but Jonathan our way from Chicago
yeah all right now this is all for now
this is Northfield North feel but it's
different improv then I'm in st. louis
st. louis funny bone coming up the
second week in April man so great shows
in San Jose San Jose coming up next
month to San Jose improv your way
everywhere I go yeah man yeah man I hear
about you man I i hate i had the stories
it's always good stories oh cuz you hear
the stories a good comments a bad
comments but it's always good store a
ride man I was good star hang on front
if some [ __ ] out there that
don't have good stories no man report
comes in you know comedy don't chip
Kamuzu oh yeah hey I trip on them that
like when I show up like I give though I
ever each other every night they see a
waitress I give her a tip you know
10,000 night whatever I have over two
shows 20 but she'll thank you thank you
and then I was just taking me hugging me
up the ass but sometimes don't [ __ ]
to do
company still to this day people with
with money yeah trust me with with with
what I have a lot of money and they'll
have a green room tab of like you know
five six seven seven hundred hours or
more and won't leave a dime always that
and then cuss him out that's crazy oh
[ __ ] tip yeah the custom on treat her
like crap right damn man [ __ ] got three
babies at home man hast tommy t's tell
me that like Tommy just join me yeah
love Tommy tease me so it's only one
common club I did I you know that i
really had a problem with punch that
Sacramento know is that lets us go look
at saddle man they're never had me back
man I mean the manager didn't see eye to
eye and I and I've never had any running
for any any manager what you're gonna
get people from Guam do tomorrow is even
go on I don't know even at the use of
something else or you tell him out that
Club bomb the parlor when the ball yeah
I didn't ever have me also owes a night
a great time you know but the manager
didn't like me the parlor barbro huh
they closed the one in see I don't know
they have the power really yes yellow
clothes the 1i sent that they sent em
all whatever no that's true about the
one other those are upstairs right that
one's open as parlor bar and right and
Bellevue but they have another one in
Seattle where I will then it was closed
now oh that's the one it's closed the my
god I'll never play any of them again
who didn't like me at all I'm really
they having that big ass pool table yeah
sometimes my like you can surprise like
you get there and everything taken care
of okay it'll be a good club nice room
but think it's the club and man more
popular idiots yeah I stopped going to
the water that every improv because the
managers there he don't want to give me
a ride to the store after the show which
man was the club there no more there was
a the what's in the Mike Mike Jones
something like that he was a manager
from Casey is one of those do what are
you talking about me a stand up and then
became man now he was always calling me
to my Jason cuz you're black bro hahaha
that's why I ball do you close at reason
he's an um nothing richmond now yeah he
was our Madison where and
and he scores because you're a ton of
telling us I got a date guys I have a
date and I said don't you sure you have
a day marked okay lying on that i really
like men is the way the whole week he
was telling us about chicks and stuff
just to I guess get them off the gate
tip or something yeah we finally I've
never got that from you know we got it
right away we got a right away and
another night and the last night we were
trying to get to the gas station right
there just to buy some water some soda
yeah I might have to clock so I say
screw yeah there you go and then we sure
he's had a bad day we showed up on the
night of the show on Thursday and the
green room was dirty and I was at the
old ass bleep oh damn chunk of hands of
Colorado man the iljin old man like it
took that for two days to put a heater
in the [ __ ] nice box and hitting a
heater he brought blankets hahaha who
the [ __ ] were a poncho before the show
there's no here like [ __ ] Mexican
cowboy hat during [ __ ] Monica it's like
a young guns and [ __ ] since not a fire
degree yeah that was he's not he's at
these night at dinner anymore yeah but
they shouldn't manager every six bucks
before him it was i'm sal kanal canal oh
hey man my name is how could now don't
know that there is from what the funny
bones now the funny born in Nam st.
Louis he's a comedian to tour the
comedian really oh my god there's a ring
at a car door on stage I'm serious I met
Albert mundo and now we talked about
that cow what's her name al canal canal
he was managing the Denver improv and
I'm he should dress up like he's about
to go too long though about to go to
that big Kentucky Derby we're big ass
hats looking at he draws cartoons so he
was a comic any magic love ya Daisy good
time mm-hmm hidden due time on our show
banana he would have I remember what
kind of [ __ ] joke this buoy should
say young man i'm off a little whack he
go he's too well now did you grow up on
stay with a car door are you saying you
know said side were like he's driving
yeah he'll go like this this is my
personai sure of the birds of the movie
the bird and every thought is going what
it's my personal zmuda wat what the [ __ ]
you say you [ __ ] and then just stick
his finger out the bird yeah bro exactly
bro buzz killington how you still cringe
will you see bad comedy yeah man i do
man is this cuz there's a thing I'm such
a fan economy man like when I'm onstage
man I and my mama Joe Fox my boy man
opens for me a lot of times so Joe Fox
yes shut up to Joe Fox man I'm telling
you if I have a always have a great set
I mean can think have a great time but
sometimes I don't like my set and people
don't wonder why I don't like my set out
all this was done cuz I'm like this man
every time I'm on stage I feel like I'm
representing stand-up comedy live comedy
cuz you never who's come to a comic lo
for the first time and I don't want to
be the one who [ __ ] it up for everybody
else I'll be the one unfunny cat that
somebody came to your live show like I'm
not funny and then the next thing you
know they never come to see live
stand-up again they won't come back ever
and make them see Joe are you they won't
come back to see me so it's like I feel
like every time I'm on stage I gotta
give I got it I'm going balls to the
[ __ ] wall because I feel like I'm
holding a banner for stand-up comedy and
I want to be I want I want to preserve
this [ __ ] I'm saying so so when I see
somebody is bad that goes up man i'm
like [ __ ] man [ __ ] you know and i gotta
tell them i can't just not i can't not
let it go press if i'm hosting oh you're
gonna hear about i don't hear about it
or if you of your daughter said that's
[ __ ] up you're doing somebody else's
joke you gonna hear about i'm at a bunch
of the sides a man you know you know
this [ __ ] went funny that she went funny
or that somebody else's Joker up to
somebody was doing Joe Fox's joke one
time I until I put due to the size a man
that's my boys joke so I mean yeah I
cringe when I see bad comedy cuz i was i
mean i didn't start out great either but
I said I'm as bad as some of these other
[ __ ]
let me just move the microphone to go
see me better I just flew in from a
ladder boy to my arms hurt I'll and
it'll be a great town once they finish
it i iook how much you blame the
audience oh it's never is never ours as
well guarantee i bring them paris things
like this is like we're outnumbered how
can two 300-400 [ __ ] be wrong
we'd only were right rolla guess I've
never blame an audience never blame
audiences cuz if you keep playing with
audience did then you won't think you
you don't think you need to work on
something yourself you know what I mean
then one folks came out to have a good
time whatever the sports bar and they
just shut off the playoff game and then
you're gonna boo everybody and what you
do is you don't go to [ __ ] up I know
when outer gilbertus kerrville oh
there's your money yeah half the money I
a made it this is things like man but if
I see the roommate conducive for my [ __ ]
i will just put the jutsu esophageal koi
you you look at Isis you suicide bomber
right then you got your comment vest on
get all those days is that dude give it
up your next comment incoming oh that's
lesson lonely's [ __ ] filler do when
you bomb it man oh yeah man it's like oh
yeah listen the three arrows she's a
poison arrow through my home you can
have you can have a thousand shows all
right and you and you can get a
celebration a thousand [ __ ] shows
that thousand one show when you bomb it
you re-evaluating your career like man
what did I make the wrong career to I
mean that's out that's all that's not
your right your house you have
everything in your house the big screen
not that I have one you can have a nice
car when you get home it feel like
there's nothing there like your MMC [ __ ]
you start you can't money in the bank
you start doubting your wife man are we
broke you don't wanna have sex after
that you don't feel sexy no damn
you don't know says you know consumer
you have a great session chances out you
dicks hard you rated you wait are you
ready to break some girls back Tom you
like man you feel the man sometimes you
have a bad said man you get up some chit
don't have set with you cuz she don't
know [ __ ] about comedy right wow you
like the best yeah but turn your head
going muffin you don't know [ __ ] I'm
bobbing at a [ __ ] oh I had ten tires
to redeem myself tonight I'm vomiting oh
nothing and that's the easiest [ __ ]
spot I said you see the host box oh yeah
how bad is yeah it's bad you know it's
so bad sometimes I eliminate the whole
sometimes like you know what two men
show [ __ ] the hoes I'll make the
announcement the headliners never make
the number cuz sometimes I get some
little green guy man and and and
especially when you've already we well
this is the thing when you got a little
they put a little white guy up and it's
all urban audience yes we had a nice
sweater though in glasses oh they look
at him they look at them over they took
they dig out in church man I swear to
god somebody help him so yeah yeah he's
trying and like I said I go on stage all
but let you know I'm so I gotta address
it I'm not gonna act like that [ __ ] just
didn't happen in front of me you gotta
dress him at that elephant in the room
exactly who just left side exactly but
they learn from them and when I used to
when I first out to a stand that man I
used to host the common acting and I was
the carbon hood and I was still green
myself I hosted a mature amateur part
right so every time they wound up and
bombed man I will go up and and talk
about I just bring a dictionary on stage
and I said let's look up the definition
joke and I read every joke and then I'll
talk on then there's let's look up funny
so there but what it did was I'll tell
you what it did it made the comments go
home and write because they come back
next week 12 not know what not bomb
again they said man I'm ready this week
I'm ready this weekend go talk about me
this week so I was doing an accidental
purpose or even make these foods go on
the right let's just get on stage for
free [ __ ] drink the way song is this
time like that [ __ ] that
who's now get hurt huh hell yeah you
can't say [ __ ] don't nobody want some
[ __ ] hear that [ __ ] like you like the
young comics have a good set and you
walk up to him they walk up to you man i
don't wanna watch your common sense i
think i stay back well coach we met when
what are getting paid like yeah let me
know collie lon I first of all right you
guys I guess first of all we're about
trying to get paid like him gotta run in
the room baby steps huckabay this guy
just made all the door here then paint
none of you guys it moves worry about
the hose that's true that guy does run
in this comedy conscious many years
nimesh real question both y'all quest
are you feel about that the the internet
the Instagram and Twitter sensation it's
comics who are have the followers but
then now they're headlining rooms and
things like that a man just keep doing
your show that eleven in the morning for
them kids okay Twain's look tweeners cuz
there's a thing man it's like do you
guys I do like those big flowers man but
still work on your craft and builds your
act cuz you got like a million followers
man and you're going stage you gotta
have more than that what you're putting
on Twitter when you put it on Instagram
and I've seen a lot of comics who have
the followers but they don't have they
don't have the act and and and and
people leaving those shows upset leave
no shows mad because like man I you know
after three minutes after five minutes
you know it was done that was that there
was out of bullets or Twitter comedian
they came out of nowhere bro right Rob
Delaney let me tell you man it is easier
to find the [ __ ] the Malaysian plane
did you find Rob Delaney said on Jimmy
Kimmel I found it every tweeted it oh my
god bro that was whoo I think it took me
like three and a half hours of financial
wouldn't find the Malaysian plane fast
as you can find Rob Delaney said on
Jimmy Caan Jimmy Kimmel man it was
cringe-worthy bro yeah oh my god we got
better after that I'm a couple of books
I must
what about stand-up comedy I'm gonna
stick to the Twitter feed instead was
killing it on Twitter I'm hope hope
butter a joke 765 tweets another one
7,000 retweets goes up on and [ __ ]
dog first of all man if you never read
this guy had never did open mics had
never done really stand up those games
and they throw him on stand up with
jimmy kimmel and it was like I don't
know this game of being on the road it
was like a bad you know being in bad
clubs or going to the mall with time to
teach to pass a flyer jawani that's
without tickets in your sleep running
drug dealer promoters oh yeah yeah
exactly what would load on some of the
money they just went in picked up made a
pickup come on they all know about they
all know about this game yeah I'm gonna
know about this game didn't want to see
I don't I get paid by the guy Pierre
haha better happen to you know gonna be
a new eyes I'd kill that [ __ ]
Pierre to know he'd never play that [ __ ]
with me but I used to be every but was
my is my cat man but I used to I used to
book comics and send him over to Guam
for Pierre those I get a paid seven
hundred dollar round trip or 1700 but
something like that yeah I used to book
commerce and sent him over to go on cuz
I'm like I'm I said him out he wanted me
to come every week why not I can't come
every week man I said you know what
about decision comics every damn with
you know and do that way and you save
that money and have gift gift comics a
chance to go and fly and do some road
games because that's when you grow you
grow in the road these are local clubs
in LA a good and stuff but you don't
groan triana rochas and you see comics
who say local and they look [ __ ] town
and then they they go to a TV appearance
and they doing all local ass jokes that
no one [ __ ] gets so traveling the
tablet is important in any sensor to
stand up show to a ladder talking about
it will have a food for less over here
[ __ ] no food for less it was a comical
def jam today from st. Louis Lee is on
stage man and and I'm telling you they
were looking at he'll do he would sell
my local st. Louis references street
name just enough for hot pot hot sauce
y'all give it up for that art enough
about my homie hot south mad and smoke
me out Daniel Russel def jam show then
eat na
oh I did yeah this is this is another
common for hot sauce hot sauce was just
like ketchup whatever it was mild sauce
he's mouths us I'm top from del taco so
you married men you get your horse man
divorce yeah mantha Last Comic Standing
she left [ __ ] out of me man that's a
lesson that [ __ ] dead no no I got I
was separated at the time man but now
I'm divorced no kids you know my
pineapple game is where she is yes man
are you allowed to fire that but they
gonna drink these babies [ __ ] that no
pretty babies yeah none don't want them
good enough know how do you do that amen
will you get married you don't have sex
with you Mary had sex with a married I
do it should I have another baby i'm
trying to get I trying to have I'm
trying to be like the only comic with
that has relationship and kids just for
the material I know I hate only one and
my wife trying to have a my wife and I
trying to have a baby I might we have a
son he's gonna be younger than my kids
kids ghetto fabulous Mike it'll be like
my son and my was my son and my older
son would be 27 years apart it's my
little ooh yeah 26 next year yeah well I
thought you grew up in California are in
the same neighborhood as I'm that
comedian I'm Alex Thomas now man the
Braille area but yeah we're not great
for st. Louis man no it's what happen if
they're oh he's broke we always at
comics I don't know man noise ask dad
what I asked there was this comedian man
who was like legend legend I mean here's
take a five-minute clip cuz I'll take a
five-minute segment of one movie and
make a 20 and may I make a 20-minute bit
IM funny man engaging and looking blue
eyes women loved him yes women love them
I mean he had this Ironside joke that
was off the chain
haha theaters ha comedy hell joke about
you know people bombing it going down
the hill totally go man so Joe when he
want to hear it yeah I'm better remember
a joke but he had a joke when he was as
good he was go down he was he was step
he was act like they're going down
understand he would get smaller and
smaller man it was oh yeah I remember
that joke yeah yeah yeah it was a beast
man but I think I don't know me was I
think I don't know I think he slept with
the wrong girl and some I made a phone
call oh that's messed up I think he's
never the wrong ex-wife and and no phone
call was made and set some [ __ ] down
yeah nothing happens you're a Jew you
keep sleeping the right girls my girls
are white right girls any question was
really scared nah dude so you're from
st. Louis what do you think about all
that Mike Brown [ __ ] in the black lives
matter most razy man because it happened
really two blocks for my mom left damn
it's funny what happened I just lost my
dad we just buried my dad two weeks
before that my mom was home by itself 15
years ago my brother and I brought i
press the house out of the hood into
that neighborhood which was a great
neighborhood 15 years ago but I'm Lee
white back then okay so when the
Ferguson should happen man they live in
love of adjacent little city called
Elwood and Ferguson was two blocks over
so I was like scared when I was that I
was back in LA I'm edited you know some
video for to put my presentation getting
for my documentary and seeing in it is
on the back and then like Ferguson
Missouri that I'm looking at my what the
[ __ ] and I see all the burning and
riding and never worry about my mom's
i'm not yo my mom it's a church lady
speaking tongues keep holy water my mom
is that she she's yet and oil she might
she annoys my order a bunch of noise my
phony with oil every time he comes to LA
I go home so I'm like mom you gotta get
out the house they do is pandemonium
they break their burning [ __ ] down go
save my sister crosstown she's like no
and it's getting smaller pockets and I
was like my date they don't lead they
they go on in neighborhood she said I
ain't scared i got my my holy water my
rosary and my baseball bat I like my
[ __ ] condemned or is not vampire
the [ __ ] are you talking about you 77
years old and she's like I can take him
I said I all right they gonna take that
back beach as where they go drink the
holy water and put that cross running
necklace fastener all these damn days so
I was I was I was [ __ ] up over because
that area of Ferguson has always been
like that when I was growing up in st.
Louis I look a little shorty let's check
the state over there right and it
whenever I would drive over there the
cops are pulled me over for no reason
that's why I did make sure I wasn't
driving dirty because they always put me
over after why I said look you got to
come [ __ ] me cuz i ain't coming over
them i'm tired of getting pulled the
[ __ ] over just gonna get a piece of ass
so i had to start coming to the city to
come see me after a while but but so
when it happened it was no surprise that
people say look cuz that area always
been races like that hands down it's
finally putting on the National map yeah
I mean and iono and again you know in a
weird way it's like I feel like what all
these shootings is going on unarmed
black men are stuff black president the
man think they can't get the Obama so
they gonna get to the closest [ __ ] desi
and it happened to be us all the okay
blaziken president it's gonna take a
long time no well no well we'll have a
woman president uh this year and then
you know next in line a why not Ted Cruz
they only have to go back to white why
do cuz why people gonna go crazy layer
hey bit of larosa that was the MV
president the people were putting all
the money are still white old man oh of
course coach brothers coke yeah and it
calls the [ __ ] am at corporate
[ __ ] money on both sides yeah yeah
and now it won't ask cotton money that's
still around yeah yeah and we're about
to make Cuba our 51st state in 2025 man
i'm so glad they lifted that [ __ ] and
using the Cuban women is gonna be coming
over legally now you can't man I let's
go that far brush with a bang bros massa
pastries a penis you know what's up
bring us on the road he spends time
alone coleen coleen de let it go file
again Joe files party that comedian like
me brother comedian met with [ __ ]
drawers down car
from Deming what's the wireless again
can't get porn hub right now what I do
I'll tell him how you [ __ ] wireless
you boy hey you know what i did i start
to bring my own the tribal when i got my
love my love my love jetpack little
internet your marriage my wife will find
that [ __ ] haha what is the history man's
what you see when you come clear that
rouser clear that browse before you go
home the other browser buster Howard
those are def ten tors man in the
beginning crazy dog off the change but
they pay well I heard they pay well well
for me I was young comment coming up so
I was getting paid at that point
thousand dollars a show this is 94 more
than man with gun without more than me
Anakin locals tonight and we doing like
334 shows in a weekend so they pay for
everything I mean is a young kid you
know was 22 years two and a half years
and you pay a thousand thousand dollars
a gig I was like hell yeah got mighty
fixing everything you see American
insurrection see my old ass grill [ __ ]
up man so cortijo comes to ya hurry yeah
the back of the day google and we all
gotta taste this chris rock on his
t-shirt Martin got his teeth fixed when
to show got his chief is effing I said
I'm getting my [ __ ] fit yes ma'am and a
man had messed up teeth in the best of
curl leavers the pool party teeth yeah
yeah but he was still he was still
[ __ ] Rosa hell yeah don't you marry
her he had a had a hell of a pimp game
do ever do you ever like I'm see
convenient that blew up and you say mad
I [ __ ] don't pick don't give
back to the community uh I haven't seen
one yet be honest nothing that I mean
you know I haven't honestly not not a
not that not nobody my error my and out
and I era basically you know Kevin gives
back you know cat cat gives back too
much something that's enough hun letter
bills at the Laugh Factory but he adopt
a lot of kids too so cat definitely no
cat gears back well my brother I'm
trying to get adopted a cat a cat a
Dobby minute join the cat back
so what's up fool or jiggle what's your
Instagram people don't know at Rodriguez
Jr what is your Instagram that guy torry
guy2 rry for everything Twitter
Instagram whatever and my website gotcha
we live com I'm not what does your
brother one time and I said what's up
guy and he said hi back you're like that
[ __ ] what even know man my little
brother dog yes you're taller than him
huh I'm Charlie he's wider I knew you
were he's wide I knew you were when I
walked away I stuck a day tomorrow he's
better built better looking just not as
funny your brother was good in that
movie but yeah both good actors hey man
you got everyone else beat he said you
gotta eat in this [ __ ] town you
better learn how to do some [ __ ] I begun
to our dishes menace saw I suck at
auditions oh I a lot i suck it out if I
if I was better at our dishes I I'd be
in more movies most moves the rules i
got i was given or i really wanted the
part and I really auditions like really
say a lot of [ __ ] man and sometimes it's
like [ __ ] man you get tired of playing
the same [ __ ] and I'm not that
attractive so I don't get the good
looking roles always get them I mean the
homos a crackhead or in jail unless you
know you [ __ ] you make that
good look I get the attractive Lee
challenged as rose I get the Middle
Eastern Greek new you I can see that
henchman yeah it's been a man but you
know what I played the villain most of
times man and it's good you ain't got
you ain't gotta worry about getting
manicure you want to wash your ass you
can just be dirty and grimy as your
Villa you posed to be nasty looking like
that you play when you play the hero the
lead man you gotta wear about getting
your hair cut out honestly man you think
man on that Shore Empire you could have
casted someone I was better than Chris
Rock for that role honestly and why the
dr david had to change his eyes for that
room view river has blue eyes for that
role hair brown eyes can we have two
brother with blue eyes the Terrans say
what is what when he'll even
hey man a man who can you can't be uh
you can't be held a blue eyes like me
man oh you cannot even read no dear I
can be on the show your tool asking
brother with blue eyes me better
protection glasses on me is that the
tears hour and crash a mate and made
your heart out and it in the preps
commercial a man you got drink this
person is theirs out if I hey man you
gotta turn armor hey Iron Man Man hey as
I was a second man you a man you go
ahead to quit doing any main a memory
man hey hey ray man man man I'm coming
man hey wait hey Empire yeah I love
Chris that's what he'll my call me my
rush more man but uh yeah that the
Empire was pretty uh yeah yeah it was it
was it was not doing that all igloo
[ __ ] that could have played that
role Hayami my other way is good about
gonna use that check Chris don't need
that check I know I always always feel
like that like even I'm in the old days
when I'm i read an article when i'm jay
leno had a Pepsi comer a Doritos
commercial and the other comedian when I
passed away that everybody consider him
as a cop comedy god bill hicks bill heck
no heck said like he needs the money hey
spending on his tonight show money
thanks Benny and now man oh no man you
got another stone we have another show
yeah yeah guys with cars yeah she like
that right I think you can save a lot of
money man if you just weren't denim for
the rest of your life a little bucket
western wear down huh no shirt
underneath and then you get to eat well
at the comedy magic club yeah theories
you have to spend money on good food cuz
they don't feed a lout you out there
that's funny don't get I'm sure club
your dad has one huh it's the worst [ __ ]
but with mom shores today an obama fan
four thousand apologies nobody once you
see jay len on a tank top but it has the
same body I've way new that's like
that's like saying precious in a thong
wasn't a [ __ ] hell no hey man wait hey
man you got Felipe Esparza hear me hey
man what's going on yellow yeah man hey
man was so full guy torry in the house
on the west abu podcast hell yeah you
any more any more days you want to
mention people could watch you today i
should be off friday yeah this bill
friday well you know if you're in denver
this weekend come out to the improv
you're in st. Louis a couple of weeks
from now in the seventh to tenth I'm
there I'm in San Jose three weeks after
that two weeks after that and in April
just check out my website you smoke weed
I can't man all right only when i'm
having sex okay man you have a sex i
can't do it all right asset anyways man
let jose check it out check out guy
torry berman you live in san jose try
everybody that guy torry showing up
taking me some tortillas please oh yeah
my friend armors so goes through the
show Birdman and check him out fight get
whatever they want for him bro he needs
get it for him come on Bay Area yeah
area and back down yeah mad cuz it'll do
ray don't know more in san jose improv i
guess they do know kind of press you
gotta shake everybody's hand at the end
every show last time i was there man i
was at the same night kevin hart was in
man kevin hart was a block away damn
that my show the rest shows were great
but to show that night like what give it
up let's give it up loud crowd yeah i
can save he was like an hour way half
our way was literally like a block away
[ __ ] on a thursday night to the damn
[ __ ] keV little did I could ruin my
night light that would be if Cinco than
mine was right outside the door what's
up fool thank you for being our podcast
hey thanks well you know how is fun man
well drew go anything if i can plug the
show on a ice house stage to april
fifteenth 815 tax day
hell yeah our hundreds episode show
where the ice house april twenty eight
o'clock april twenty what lineup coming
soon okay so a sale now april twenty the
100 episode live at the ice house april
twenty eight o'clock rodrigo and i will
be hosting where our suits are you
selling suits hey don't her denver just
got a blizzard damn are you kidding me
that happened to me a couple of weeks
ago I was in Baltimore and got snowed in
this is so crazy now that I was at the
bottom of comedy factory and they put
you up on this beautiful hotel I mean
beautiful two big-ass jacuzzi in the
room the whole nine council I did the
show Thursday night right friday i go
get up to get up early go do press did
all [ __ ] press cancel Shani [ __ ] shut
the city down nobody go anywhere I got
snowed in the hotel for four days a
beautiful big beautiful hotel I'm snowed
in there was not one pretty [ __ ]
standing hotel that I could bang and put
my tub and then have the workers come
the workers came and stayed in hotel
well nothing business [ __ ] I'm like
I'm in this beautiful hotel sitting the
bar getting drunk going back looking at
you pawning my hotel room every night
Netflix and chill pornhub and 20 nude
africa calm or wife lovers or I gotta
check that one out hey every tell you
something though this is a good day just
when i first started or economy you had
to buy it on your TV but but the cool
thing about it was you got five minutes
to preview before they charge you so you
had to like be i have us at a system had
one like NBA shot clocks on the TV calm
down and like so i had to have the
lotion and i have had to get that thing
I'm like okay fine looking killer 31
it's okay because you don't want to get
charged for that [ __ ] now we got the
internet good man thank you yeah man on
man if those bangbros a walrus do is
just be jerking off cutting the front
they say what are you doing we're doing
give me a wake up car what time in
o'clock eight o'clock eight o'clock was
so vu